President Biden resisting calls to tell
Americans what he knows about those
mysterious unidentified objects he has
ordered the military to shoot down
Senators finally getting a classified
briefing but they left frustrated with
the lack of answers so far from the
Biden Administration
President Biden should speak on camera
directly to the American people today
the American people need and deserve to
know more
there is a lot of information presented
to us this morning
that could be totally American people 99
of the information we were just briefed
on there's no reason it can't be shared
with the American people it was a
bipartisan view down there
and it's pretty simple they can say what
they know
what they don't know and don't reveal
sources and methods right and right on
cue the White House Press Secretary
dismissing bipartisan concerns while
saying President Biden while he's doing
a stellar job
great the president is taking this very
seriously and he's receiving briefings
regularly from his National Security
advisors and he's going to continue to
do that we are sharing as much
information as we can there's no need to
panic the president took this action as
I mentioned earlier because of the
objects were indeed flying at low lower
elevation and they were in civilian
airspace and we wanted to make sure that
we protected that airspace one of the
reasons that people are saying the
commander-in-chief should speak is one
uh for reassurance I'm not sure that's
reassurance right especially if they're
mocking people for having concerns
they're the ones who said that the
Chinese spy flight was not a problem
then they shot it down then all of a
sudden they're shooting things out of
the sky and they don't give an
explanation for it and Jesse There was a
pretty bad inflation report today so
between that and the balloon now that
maybe have the president stay home like
in the East wing for a month you won't
hear from him or the train yeah a lot
going on
what president could get away with
shooting down
unidentified flying objects all over
North America and then not talk about it
for days could bush get away with that
imagine but he wouldn't try
none of them would try none of them
would try right
but it makes you think why why is he
doing because he's not in command that's
why he doesn't know what he's doing he
doesn't even know what these objects are
it looks like these might have just been
weather balloons he got trigger happy
because his pollsters said he looked
like an idiot for letting the Chinese
balloon spy on us the entire way across
the continent and so now it's like
anything that flies dies but he's
keeping you quiet
no I heard it from Greg
and missiles are missing the balloons
like we're missing stuff and we can't
find the debris The debris floating over
and he's called the lid Dana the man is
called the lid I I I I just I just can't
and all the country wants is come out
five seconds and tell us what's going on
what's the strategy because at first
they said we're going to be patient and
shoot it later and now they're not
patient at all they're just shooting
anything right and then they're saying
well don't worry about it it's not
aliens don't worry also it's like
why not take the opportunity to talk to
the American people they could people
can take a judge if you say we're not
sure what they are but we're on top of
it and as soon as we know we'll give you
more information isn't that the reason
he was elected because he was so
sensitive about coven he was so
reassuring Americans could count on his
sensitivity here's the bottom line never
in American history if we have we had
F-22 Raptors shooting off Sidewinders
over the continental United States this
is unheard of in in the in the in the
United States these are air battles this
president has an obligation to tell us
what he knows and what he doesn't know
and I am so sick and tired of karee
Jean-Pierre and her word salads she says
that three objects are now being
recovered the weather prevents them from
being recovered but we're going to get
those objects we're going to continue to
try we're going to continue to be
vigilant but we think they may be benign
what the hell what that what did that
mean and here's the bottom line if there
are air battles going on he has an
obligation to talk to the American
people whether it is we don't know what
it is or we shot too often or we
shouldn't have done it right he is too
weak and I'll tell you what they what
the worry is in the White House
according to a source that I have
they're afraid he's going to go out and
say stupid things because they can't
trust him to talk to the American people
that and or they're waiting for someone
to blame that could be it all I know is
it feels like we're in this era where
it's again not against the law but
you're shamed if you notice things yeah
it's like where are you since when is
there like is it wrong to be curious
about the government blowing stuff up in
the sky it's like how dare you ask it's
okay to ask We're not gonna give you an
answer but when they've given us so much
BS on inflation remember inflation was
good for a while it's actually healthy
and crime where they denied that there
was a crime epidemic we can talk about
war we can talk about covid there are so
many times the government has lied to us
and then they dismiss our curiosity and
while they're doing it they're still not
explaining it I'm thinking about this
like if you if a parent talks about drag
queen Story Hour which is they don't
have a problem with it they just don't
think it's age appropriate you know how
do you're a homophobe if you're talking
about the balloons you must be a
conspiracy freak if you talk about the
train duramet conspiracy freak if you
talk about food plants blowing up you're
a real freak you know voting
discrepancies you could get sued right
FBI informants don't say that sex you
know sex Advocate anything that you
actually go like
hey I just want to know I just want to
know I'm not saying there's something
wrong there I just want to know what's
going on then they go you're an idiot
stop listening to the to those podcasts
right so Geraldo do you think you'll
hear from him
what we have to it's leading to rampant
speculation and I've only seen one UFO
I've sailed around the world I've been
in uh 140 countries I've only seen one
at UFO and I was stoned was it a weather
I had no idea it was in the in the
waters of uh the nation of Bahamas uh
but what is interesting to me is this
silence is leading to more talk of UFOs
than I have heard it but not in a in a
disrespectful or or a condescending way
but you know ordinary reasonable normal
people talking about unidentified flying
objects and aliens and so forth yeah you
can't let that spread you've got to tell
us what the hell is it it should not be
if you could brief 90 I don't know how
many senators they were at that meeting
today but you know it's going to leak if
you tell a senator anything eventually
today so far it hasn't all day and I'm
surprised by that but it will I mean why
not tell us what the hell it is it's got
to be surveillance over Americans these
are surveillance balloons and they have
to figure out the story to feed it to us
because these balloons are actually ours
we're shooting down our balloons because
they're watching you and they're no
longer necessary that has to be the
story but what if it's uh something that
is so benign and they use two
Sidewinders they miss with one and it's
like euron it's beautiful pristine
wonderful wonderful part of the Great
Lakes what if it's us what if it's like
some kids science project and they're
four hundred thousand dollars a piece
400 000 each missile plus I hear
Sidewinders don't miss
that all about yeah what if it's a guy
in a lawn chair
remember that there were those guys who
used to like put balloons and just fly
remember the kid that was supposedly
went swept away yeah boom boy I went on
Brian kill Mead I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not gonna miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now